it's almost as almost Civil War like so
like people are being turned against
each other like brother against brother
friend his friend it's just a very tense
climate right now my name is Danny days
I'm an artist musician and activist now
hey I basically switched my life around
a lot i still create north still in the
same subject matter but I taking a much
bigger role in a actually organized have
a friend at a childhood friend I drew us
or a white guy who's a cop at this point
he's a target and I'm a target so he
calls me and sex on me and I called him
and said on him it would put police at
peace it will put the neighborhood of
people directing the community at peace
if they were just own up and take some
accountability but if things keep going
the way they've been going it's gonna
get a lot worse before it gets better